i also think that this language that he
uses
when he talks about the matrix and he
talks about the resistance you know i i
use the system i always talk about the
system and
people who are not necessarily you know
watching tate or haven't been followers
of tape they will understand this
language because they get it and what we
mean by that people like me when we say
that is we're talking about the media
establishment we're talking about
silicon valley the media establishment
the big pharma establishment everyone
seems to be holding hands so this is
this is a conversation that people are
going to be attuned to immediately he
says the matrix someone like my husband
who's not you know hasn't been following
andrew tate says uh i love what he's
saying about that because they're
plugged into the fact that there's a lot
of manipulation happening from the top
down and they want us to be puppets
people by and large are not signing up
for that anymore in the spaces that i uh
gravitate toward